[Music]
well back here at home a Las Vegas dance
instructor is taking his passion a step
further by providing free classes to the
underserved Community Victoria Saha
takes us through how intense City Dance
is changing lives for our youth put our
foot out on one Calvin Turner's passion
for dance is intense push what does
dance mean for you dance means love
passion for me Turner took a spin on the
floor at 14 years old and never looked
back there were times where I didn't
feel comfortable with myself I didn't
feel good at all for myself but I got
into that dance studio and everything
just phased away for me Turner went from
dancing on the Las Vegas trip to make
ends meet to So You Think You Can Dance
then taking a leap by opening his own
dance studio called intensity dance and
hold hit not this time swaying kids from
underprivileged communities to use dance
as an outlet with free classes some kids
just need a confidence boost
participants Tayla and Taylor each found
their own Rhythm for their life in
Turner's Studio whether it's with ballet
I can feel my expressions and I can just
be free or with tap
before I was happy now I'm super super
super very very very happy it gives me a
sense of accomplishment that I was able
to change that kid's life in a certain
way and the trio let me in on a couple
of their dance moves
okay I think I may just stick to my
reporting job Victoria Saha 8 News Now
classes at intense City start at seventy
dollars a month for one class a week and
toddlers to adults can all participate
but if you know of a child that could
use his free program we're going to have
information on our website on how you
can sign up